good morning everyone and welcome to the
London School of Economics and political
science welcome to those here in the
room as well as those who are listening
online
my name is veena Shafiq and i'm the
director of the London School of
Economics and political science in 23
days the UK will leave the European
Union after a difficult period of
political uncertainty and negotiation
but leaving will not be the end of the
UK's relationship with the EU a
relationship built on a shared history
shared values and similar hopes for the
future what will this new relationship
look like to set out her vision of the
crucial next steps I am delighted to
welcome president Ursula van der Leyen
president of the European Commission
back to the LSE today now some of you
may have noticed in the announcement of
today's event that it referred to dr.
van der Leyen
as an LSD alumna first and president of
the European Commission for a second you
may think we have got the order wrong
but it simply reflects how proud we are
of her achievements as a former student
of the school a place where she herself
has said she found an inner freedom
which which has stayed with her ever
since and which has led her to go on to
being the longest-serving cabinet
minister in Tulsa Merkel's government
and most recently as the first woman to
serve as Germany's defence minister and
now as president of the European
Commission
and we are also proud of her daughter
who is a graduate of the school and her
other daughter who will soon be joining
the school so it is a long and very
personal and close relationship but
moving on to her current role as
president of the European Commission the
topic of her speech today old friends
new beginnings building a new
relationship a new future for the EU UK
partnership could not be more welcomed
and more timely at this particular
moment now just a few logistics for
Twitter users the hashtag for today's
event is hashtag LSE Europe and this
event will be recorded and podcast and
available for live streaming there will
be time for questions after the lecture
and I'll take questions from members of
the public and students and also take
some questions from the press as well so
please join me in welcoming dr. Ursula
van der Leyen
president of the European Commission
[Applause]
thank you very much what a pleasure to
be back here at London School of
Economics it is a place indeed that
brings back many many memories to me so
the year I spent one year one year only
at the London School of Economics but it
taught me so much it taught me a lot
inside
LSE and taught me a lot outside LSE as
you can guess and anyone who knew me at
that time will tell you that I probably
spent more time in Soho bars and Camden
record stores and in the senate-house
library so to spare me my own blushes
I'll spare you the details of that but
what I can say is that the time I spent
here opened my eyes I got to know a warm
vibrant colorful multicultural society
the likes of which I had never
experienced before
I saw people from different walks of
life going out together and joy in life
breathing freedom I immersed myself in
the melting pot of cultures traditions
and music indeed and I truly fell in
love with this city and this country
this country strong willed open-minded
big-hearted proud and patriotic kind and
generous and spirit full of traditions
full of contradictions too
and it took me a while to understand for
example the fantastic sense of humor of
the British people and that it is a
subtle meaning hidden in every sentence
but it's only deepened my fascination
and my admiration for the United Kingdom
which remains as strong today as it was
back then and you can imagine that in
the period just before and after the
referendum I thought a lot about my
London time I say this just not only
because of my love for this country but
also because of what the United Kingdom
has brought to Europe and the European
Union in a very understated British way
I think we do not always talk enough
about that and therefore allow me to
look a little bit back before we look
forward before the ashes of the Second
World War even settled it was Winston
Churchill who made the best case for a
united Europe
I read our passages from his 1946 Zurich
speech of famous speech the last time I
was here it is the most eloquent and
powerful case for the European Union you
could ever wish to read and if you
haven't read it I can only recommend to
do so and while the UK initially chose
to be on the outside it eventually took
its place on the inside making us both
that much stronger the relationship may
not always have been smooth or perfect
but what relationship ever is and in my
opinion the good far outweighs the
difficult as president of the European
Commission I want to pay tribute today
to all those British people who
contributed so much to the 45 plus years
of European Union membership I think of
the British pragmatism and leadership
when it came to all
opening up our union to members of our
family who have been out in the cold for
so long the successive European Union
enlargements were historic steps for our
continent and they bared British
hallmark
I think of those who helped to build our
institutions people like commissioner
Arthur [ __ ] field who was known as the
father of the single market or Roy
Jenkins he was president of the European
Commission while I was at LSE who did so
much to pave the way for single currency
I think of the European civil servants
of British nationality who devoted their
lives and their careers to Europe and
have done so much to build our Union
they will always be part of our family I
think of the British servicemen and
servicewomen who have helped to keep the
peace from the Balkans to the Baltics
and I think of the millions of ordinary
little peep British people who have
taken to the streets in pro your pian
marches in the last few years of course
[Applause]
this is one of them of course
indeed for them and for many millions
more the results of the referendum was a
bitter pill to swallow but it is people
who make politics and the decision of
the British people in the June in June
2016 was clear as much as we regret it
the European Union has always fully
respected that decision you have seen
this throughout the last three and a
half years our negotiations were hard
and they were long but the European
Union negotiated in good faith trying to
find solutions that defend our own
interests and respect the UK's choice it
is an agreement that we negotiated with
our people and the integrity of the
European Union and mind it is one that
preserves the remarkable peace and
progress on the island of Ireland over
the past 20 years and I will not go into
the ins and outs of the negotiations
under the divorce
Jesus done and dusted as far as I am
concerned before the end of the month I
expect both the British and the European
Parliament's to ratify the agreement and
so in just over three weeks on the 30
31st of January the UK will spend its
last day as a Member State this will be
a tough and emotional day but when the
Sun rises again on February 1st the
European Union and the United Kingdom
will still be the best of friends and
partners the bonds between us will still
be unbreakable we will still contribute
to each other societies like so many
Brits have done in the European Union
and as so many year many citizens do
here every single day
whereas teachers
where it's nurses as doctors we're
working as CEOs or in NGOs we will still
have a lot to learn from each other the
UK is home to thriving creative and
cultural sectors - cutting at digital
innovation and scientific excellence in
some of the world's best universities
with brilliant minds many of them from
all across Europe we will still share
the same challenges from climate change
to security we will still be allies and
like-minded partners in NATO the United
Nations and other international
organisations we will still share the
same values and the belief that
democracy freedom and the rule of law
must be the foundation of our societies
we will still share the same history and
geography and whatever happens our
continent will still share the same
destiny - so as one door will
unfortunately closed another one will
open and now is the time for us to look
forward together it is the time for the
best and the oldest friends to build a
new future together
and as only true friends can I want to
be very honest about what lies ahead of
us during the withdrawal agreement
negotiation there was always the
uncertainty around where the brexit
would happen or not
it was an uncertainty that made the
negotiations inevitably tense this fresh
negotiation ahead of us will take place
against the backdrop of clarity and
mutual interest in making it work the
European Union is ready to negotiate a
truly ambitious and comprehensive new
partnership with the United Kingdom
we will make as much as we can we will
go as far as we can but the truth is
that our partnership cannot and will not
be the same as before and it cannot and
will not be as close as before because
with every choice comes a consequence
when every decision comes a trade-off
without the free movement of people you
cannot have the free movement of capital
goods and services without a level
playing field an environment labor
taxation and state aid you cannot have
the highest quality access to the
world's largest single market the more
divergent there is the more distant the
partnership will be and without an
extension of the transition period
beyond 2020 you cannot expect to agree
on every single aspect of our new
partnership we will have to prioritize
the European Union's objective and the
negotiations are clear we will work for
solutions that uphold the integrity of
the European Union it's single market
and its customs union there can be no
compromise on that but we are ready to
design a new partnership with zero
tariffs zero cultures zero dumping a
partnership that goes well beyond trade
and it is unprecedented in scope
everything from climate action to data
protection fisheries energy transport
space financial services and to security
and we are ready to work day and night
to get as much done with
in the time frame we have none of this
means that it will be easy but we start
this negotiation from a position of
certainty goodwill shared interests and
purpose and we should be optimistic we
need to be optimistic we need to be
optimistic for those young people
leaving school in the next years who
want to study and learn abroad we need
to be optimistic and we need to look to
how British and European researchers
could work together to find solutions of
our most pressing challenges and to
develop the new technologies the world
does really need and we must ensure that
we continue to work together on
upholding peace and security in Europe
and around the world we must build a new
comprehensive security partnership to
fight cross-border threats ranging from
terrorism to cyber security to
counterintelligence
events in recent years in Salzburg
Manchester London and all across Europe
have underlined the need for us to work
together on mutual security the threat
of terrorism is real and we have to
share the necessary information and
intelligence between the European Union
and the United Kingdom to stop
terrorists from crossing borders and
attacking our way of life the nature of
today's threats means that no one can
deal with these challenges on its own
this is even more true for foreign
policies as we see today even though
Britain will be outside the European
decision-making structures there will be
plenty of need for common responses to
address foreign security and development
challenges near and far be it in our
immediate neighbourhood in the east and
south when the Horn of Africa
sahel sub-saharan Africa Oh beaten white
a Middle East or different parts of
Latin America or Asia the truth is that
brexit will not resolve any of the
existing challenges for the European
Union nor for the UK and even being a
part and not bound in the treaties it
will require intensive cooperation on
our foreign and security policies that's
essential that's essential because we
share so much experience and because we
share so many of the same values we have
to uphold these values not only when
it's easy but above all when it's hard
dear friends as we embark on this new
partnership with the United Kingdom the
European Union must also continue to
forge its own path in today's world one
consequence of the brexit vote has been
to strengthen the unity and the faith in
Europe as a project for the common good
the truth is that brexit has highlighted
the value of being together in today's
ever more unsettled world it reaffirmed
our collective belief that we can do
more when we do it together individually
the nations of Europe are becoming
smaller and less influential on the
world scale in 1950 before the Union was
formed the United Kingdom Italy and
Germany were among the 10 most populous
countries in the world 1950 today only
one lifespan later only one of those is
in the top 20
and while Europe's population is set to
decline by the end of the century
Africa's alone will grow by more than 3
billion
at the same time new economies are
emerging and all partners are retreating
back to their own path and we face
change and new challenges ahead of us
climate change for example if there is
one area where the world needs our
leadership it is on protecting our
climate it is existential for Europe and
for the whole world last month we
launched the European Green Deal the
European Green Deal is not only about
emissions is also about emissions but
not only about emissions
it's about boosting innovation it's
about clean technologies it's about
green financing it's about quality food
it's about modern mobility the European
Green Deal is our new growth strategy
and it will create new businesses and
markets in Europe and across the world
the novelty and the difference is that
we will and can foster a growth male
model that is cannot consuming or
extracting but one that gives back more
to the planet then it takes away from
the planet Great Britain is as dedicated
as the European Union when it comes to
addressing climate change and taking
global leadership a whole continent has
to mobilize and the whole world needs to
be part of this transformation the
European Green Deal won't happen
overnight and it will be demanding and
no country can hope to handle climate
change alone but if this is the right
thing to do and if we do it together we
can lead the change
dear students over the next months and
years we will have to loosen some of the
threats which have been carefully
stitched together between the European
Union and the United Kingdom over five
decades
and as we do so we will have to work
hard to weave together a new way forward
I say this because brexit does not only
mark the end of something on the
contrary it also marks a new phase in an
enduring partnership and friendship it
will be a partnership for your
generation and I count on you all to
make it a success
you can choose collaboration over
isolation you can shape your countenance
disgustin II you can hold your
governments accountable you can refuse
to be satisfied with the status quo and
you can turn things into how they should
be I know the last few years have been
difficult and divisive I hope that by
being constructive and ambitious in the
upcoming negotiation we can all move
forward together there will be tough
talks and each side will do what is best
for them but I can assure you that the
United Kingdom will always have a
trusted friend and partner in the
European Union this is the story of old
friends and new beginning and in this
good sense
long live Europe thank you
[Applause]
okay we have time for questions I'm
going to take the three at a time I'd be
grateful if they were brief I'll take
let me take the gentlemen here I'll take
the woman in the back and I will take
the woman back here in the green so yes
if the stewards could come and if you
could introduce give your name and your
affiliation and then ask your question
hi thank you very much for your speech
my name is sato Roberta I'm an alumni of
the European Institute in Alessi my
question regards the place of citizens
rights in the in the settlement between
the UK and EU that was yesterday
a leaked letter by from Michele Barney -
[Music]
not directly from you I expect about the
fact that the visual agreement bill that
the UK parliament is passing at the
moment was granting the ability of UK
Minister - what - done some rights about
the future of EU citizens rights in the
UK related to the watchdog that could
help
EU citizens have a proper ability to due
process in the case they were refused
their ability to live in the UK later on
through the set of statutes sorry it's a
bit of a nerdy question but what I'm
wondering is how should we do she uhshe
do you respond to the threat of a
watering then of uses right here in the
ongoing process of the negotiations
thank you thank you
the woman in the back right there with
her arm up and then there was a woman
here in a green top yes
thank you very much my name is Laura
Parker I'm the former European
Commission official proud European and
married to an Italian so mine is the
other half of the question that my
friend just asked which is whether you
would consider associate citizenship for
British individuals I feel torn by the
notion that we leave the EU as a
bureaucratic structure but as someone
who is loves that someone from another
bit of the EU I don't quite see how I
managed to leave it so I'd like you to
say a little bit more perhaps about
citizenship for we Brits who want to
continue to be citizens of the European
Union and thank you so much for coming
today hi my name is Georgia I'm a
master's student here at the LSE I was
really interested and what we spoke
about about sort of the pathway to
future security cooperation and I
thought especially between Britain the
EU with transnational threats and things
like bilateral disputes with the US and
China things like that what does this
partnership look like in practice in the
future could you repeat the the second
part I didn't really say and what does
the future relationship between Britain
and the EU look like combating conf
disputes in international affairs and
things like the us-china trade war yes
of course the question of citizens
rights is a pressing one so the good
news is that whoever first of all what
what the numbers are concerned we have
around 3.5 European Union citizens
living in the United Kingdom and vice
versa around 1.2 1.3 million British
citizens living in the European Union
and all those I'm just addressing those
who live in the opposite region the good
news is where you work and live
you can stay under the same conditions
till the end of your life so you have an
absolute clear status when for example
at the European you live here in the
United Kingdom
same rights same possibilities as you
have at the moment we until the end of
the life your life and vice versa in
Europe it is so that you have these
rights in the members state you live in
so if at the moment being you're
situated in Belgium or in Croatia or in
Portugal you have the right to stay and
work forever
under the same conditions in Belgium
Croatia or Portugal wherever you are
the bitter truth ban is as I've said the
UK will be third country after brexit
and then we will have to negotiate and
this applies to everything I have been
talking about so we are very open to do
the most because I'm a I'm a true
believer that as much exchange as
possible we should allow to our citizens
but as I said before if for example free
movement of people is excluded well
there is a trade-off to that and
therefore it's a matter of negotiation
where we end up at the very end you know
that the European Union is very open to
that question that we are strong
believers that we benefit both sides
very much from the free movement which
goes also for the free movement of not
only people but good services and
capital but those four principles go
together and therefore the next weeks
and month will show at what point we
will end the same goes for for example
Erasmus the same goes for reached
Research Projects whatever we decided at
28 with such projects for example we
started we will finish at 28 so the
status quo states but the future is
matter to negotiations and therefore I
insist so much on keeping in mind there
we have so many common interests that we
should build a strong future mainly if
we look around at the rest of the world
and then we realize how much we share
therefore this should be very very
careful with in these negotiations
really to achieve the most possible for
the citizens and for a good partnership
in the future the question on security
it is internal security and external
security although both are very much
interval but well officially we kind of
separated internally of course we have
to talk about things like Europol or
things like extradition what external
security is concerned there - the UK
will be a third country it can choose if
invited to take part for example in
missions or operations we will have to
negotiate about the other topics for
example being part or taking part in
projects in the European defence agency
eda there are clear rules for third
countries so the UK will be subject of
these rules for third countries or what
the European defence Union is concerned
and the European Defense Fund is
concerned the European Union itself is
at the moment in the process of defining
what the conditions are for third
countries to join specific projects and
the UK will be then a third country that
will fall under these rules of the
European Union we have if we look at the
world and enormous interest on both
sides to work as closely together as we
can you know I've been for five years
defence minister in Germany I've seen
our servicemen and our service women
fighting and working in missions
shoulder by shoulder
I've seen how they defend our values in
this very complicated world and
therefore I really recommend to
ourselves to be clear minded and
farsighted what threats are concerned
and common interests are concerned to
build a security partnership that is
unprecedented and that really meets the
purpose we are all aiming at what China
is concerned there first of all I think
it's important that where do we stand
together for me is always very clear and
the trade war you were mentioning the
potential one between the United States
and China we will never ever forget
where we come from and on what side of
the table if I may put it that way we're
sitting so I'm a strong believer in the
transatlantic partnership and friendship
although we do have issues with the
white house
but you know we're looking back on seven
decades seventy years and more of a
friendship that is built of millions of
contact in the cultural sector in
science in the business sector personal
friendship and this foundation we do
have and from that foundation on we can
tackle these issues too so to be very
clear where we are I think it is very
important that conflicts and trade we
always keep in mind who will benefit at
the very end and therefore I would be
very welcoming if they are sensible and
smart agreements we can find with China
with China we have sign as China's very
assertive China's very far reaching by
now I think we have to be very clear on
topics where we disagree very clear on
that we have to be very clear in the
cyber domain where we have a lot of
words but on the other hand there are
other topics where we have common ground
for example the topic of climate change
China's starts now to introduce the
emission trading system and is coming to
the European Union and Commission and
asking for our experience we had with
introducing the emission trading system
which is good because in an ideal world
over time fighting climate change we
need a worldwide budget of co2 with
emission trading system on it and co2
has to have a price so if we get China
long to go into that topic together with
that is good for us it's good for China
it's good for the planet but as I said
you have to be very frank on other
issues human rights cyber security where
we have huge differences
okay thank you let me turn to some
colleagues from the press maybe John
pano from BBC and then maybe James and
then Sam the coats from thank you very
much John Pina BBC News might it be
possible to agree the outline of a deal
in the time available may be covering
goods and then continue negotiating or
without a transition must it be all or
nothing by the end of the year James
James mace ITV News Madam President on a
similar note when Boris Johnson says to
you this afternoon I want a
comprehensive and ambitious free-trade
agreement and I want it by the end of
the year will you say to him yes let's
go for it or no you can't have both
maybe one wall here in the front some
case from sky geese in your speech you
suggested that we could be on track for
a zero tariff zero quota deal
what kind of obligation is one dear
examples might Britain have to adhere to
to get that or we simply offering that
here today
voila the transition time it is very
very tight and I briefly touched on the
topics we have to negotiate and this was
not even the whole list of it so it is
basically impossible to negotiate all of
what I've been mentioning and the other
dose is that there are two therefore we
will have to prioritize as long as we
face that deadline of end of 2020 and I
can only recommend that with priorities
in a way that we first of all tackle
those topics where at the end of the
year when we're running out of time we
would not have an international
agreement or something to fall back on
but only a hard exit which would not be
for the good for the UK nor would it be
good for the European Union and
therefore priority the priorities will
have to be sorted out
I'm deeply convinced that as I said for
all the fields this is huge what we have
to negotiate the I mean net 9 to 10
months at most because at the very end
it has to be ratified to will be enough
but therefore it's not an all-or-nothing
thing but it's a question of priority
priorities we have to set and we have to
work as hard as possible I would prefer
that we look at the whole scenery during
the summer or before the summer starts
would be better because we might
together want to take a reconsideration
of the time frame before the 1st of July
but let us start first of all at the 1st
of February with soaring the field and
going into the negotiations as
that we're determined to work as hard as
we can as much as we can but they're of
course limits zero quota zero tariffs
zero damping means level playing field
clear level playing field on both sides
so whatever is diverging from a level
playing field of course increases or
decreases the uncomplicated access to
the single market and for details we
would have to go through the different
fields but if you take for example no I
will not go into details because
otherwise we go through the whole
negotiation now actually more than end
of 2020 but the idea behind it is zero
Koda zero tariffs zero damping absolute
level playing field fine the more you
diverge from that the more of course of
the less the the the uncomplicated
access to the single market is there
okay thank you very much final round of
questions let me take oh so many the
gentleman back there one here and yes
over here thank you thank you very much
my name is Juan Lombardo I'm currently
posted to the Mexican Embassy here in
London and also an LSE alumni so my
question has to do with speak up just a
little bit yes my question yeah can you
hear me yeah my question has to do with
third party negotiations and
particularly with a capacity of the UK
to negotiate with those third parties
particularly with those with whom the EU
has an agreement already like a free
trade agreement so I'm one my there's a
bit of confusion here but my
understanding is that the UK will only
be capable of negotiating once they
formally leave the EU
and those third countries will be
notified by the commission that you
preside madam so my question is when
well that notification will come to
those third countries letting us know
when the UK is legally capable of
negotiating a free trade agreement and
no longer binding by the agreements that
he has as a member of the EU me Channel
four News
thank you very much for coming wonderful
speech just to get back to the question
of convergence you've laid out your
store very clearly here we also know
from members of the Bois Johnson
government that there are those who are
looking for a kind of Singapore on the
Thames model to what extent do you
perceive that to be a threat to the
interests of the European Union and what
are you prepared to do about it I think
it's okay my name is Inga I am an LSE
alumni as well and researcher with
Elysee ideas in the dahrendorf forum you
emphasised the joint challenge facing
the EU and the UK regarding security and
talked about the EU in the UK being
like-minded allies in NATO you also
mentioned the friction in the White
House given macrons recent comments the
situation in Turkey and the US military
actions do you think NATO is a viable
alliance for the future and will you
know contribute to the relationship
between the EU or the UK or do you think
it will create even more challenges
I just have to write it down I must
admit I didn't really get the question
all above but so when when will the UK
have the green light to do so party
negotiations from okay I look at
Michelle Barney when will it be the show
[Applause]
thank you know as the president said
leaving the usual activities huge and
very very many consequences and I just
want to repeat that leaving the you the
single bucket and the custom Ian means
for the UK to leave in the same time
mechanically automatically 600
international agreements among them all
the trade agreements that means that UK
has to rebuild each and every trade
agreement with all the other third
country the world tributes and a very
very important task and what we have
planned in the negotiation with women
and for the transition that the UK will
be allowed to begin and we know that
they have already begin for last year
many negotiation with many cert
countries none of this agreement can be
implemented before the UK lived and so
as a member states
they cannot implement the the
disagreement that means that they are
allowed to negotiate and we give them
this time to negotiate they cannot be
implemented before the legal either
alright we go back to Singapore question
I would not recommend that we kind of
label the end of the negotiation it will
be the EU UK brand on it and as I've
said I think we have to be very clear
that it's a matter of trade often
choices and nothing will be as it was
before all will change we have to accept
that fact so there is a difference being
a member state and not being a member
state what access
and ease is concerned and therefore the
fields will be matter of negotiation I
take a very important field that are the
financial services there - all will
change because right now we are all able
within the 28 if you have a bank that
from home you can operate in a different
Member State easily this will change
this is over and the question is you can
get for some sectors some equivalences
which is kind kind of the the being
allowed to operate that way but this is
a decision then unilateral from the
European Union and therefore a whole of
topics a lot of topics we have to go
through and figure out how we end up at
the very end of course both sides have
their strengths and their weaknesses
both sides have a field where they are
better and they are not as good off and
therefore it is a matter also of always
looking at the mutual interest we do
have at the very end we want our
economies to to prosper at the very end
we want our citizens to have an easy
life going back and forth at the very
end we want science and research and
wonderful universities like this one to
be open on the continent and here in the
UK so if this is the goal we have to try
to minimize as much as possible the
possible the deviation from the level
playing field and to negotiate as fast
and as intensive as possible to have a
smooth ongoing because again I say there
are other challenges out there in the
world we have to tackle together and
that leads me to the third question NATO
I'm deeply convinced that collective
defense article 5 in NATO will always be
NATO and this is good
NATO is the strongest military alliance
in the world and this is good too the
European Union will never be a military
alliance it's much broader and way
different and it has completely
different means and influence we have
over the last three and a half years
started to build up the European defense
union which is complementary to NATO
following the idea that as 27 it is
smart to be into a high degree
interoperable to procure together to
develop and research together this is
smart in doing it and to get our act
together if I may put it that way
it's also in NATO's interest because 22
of the European member states are also
member in NATO so it's in NATO's
interest but I see many fields besides
the purely question of collective
defence which is a very important one
we're also the European Union is being
called upon and therefore it has to get
structures and procedures as I was
saying in the European defence Union but
also the wide field of Economic
Development neighborhood diplomacy all
the topics that are needed to not only
win or settle a conflict but to win
peace than afterwards and give people a
perspective for their future and at the
moment being I always think that we
should never ever underestimate the
importance of the ability to have a
dialogue and to have trusted relations I
know that during times
where there are tensions and conflicts
that is dominant but at a certain point
in every conflict you have to go back to
talks and then it's helpful to have
established channels to have trusted
relations where you can start again to
establish some kind of link to get out
of a dramatic crisis and to work on
increased peace and reconciliation
within the region and beyond the region
and therefore I'm a strong believer that
NATO is important but I'm very much
convinced that may - also need to the
European Union thank you so much
[Applause]
I wanted to thank you for many things
but really the most important thing is
you've reminded us that the connections
between the UK and the European Union
are grounded in profound and deep
history and common interests and values
and you've reminded us that there's a
very personal dimension to those
connections and many people in this room
I think share those very personal
connections in our own relationships in
their own lives the negotiations will be
about policy policy can diverge and
policy after January 31st will probably
diverge but those personal and there's
very profound common values and interest
will persevere after January 31st and
you've reminded us to keep sight of
those much more important long-term
issues as we enter a very complicated
set of negotiations thank you for coming
and thank you for reminding us of those
big important issues
[Applause]
please remain in your seats until we're
able to get out of the room thank you
all very much for coming
[Music]
you